Traductor: Dania Méndez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Considera la siguiente oración:
“Este enunciado es falso”.
¿Eso es cierto?
Si es así,
la declaración sería falsa.
Pero si es falsa,
la declaración es verdadera.
Al referirse a sí misma directamente,
se crea una paradoja irresoluble.
Pero si no es verdadera ni falsa, ¿qué es?
Esta pregunta puede parecer
un experimento mental un poco tonto.
Pero a inicios del siglo XX,
llevó al lógico austriaco Kurt Gödel
a descubrir algo que cambiaría
las matemáticas para siempre.
El descubrimiento exploraba las
limitaciones de las pruebas matemáticas.
Una prueba es un argumento lógico
cuyo fin es demostrar
por qué una afirmación numérica
es verdadera.
Los bloques que forman estos argumentos
se conocen como axiomas,
proposiciones innegables
sobre los números involucrados.
Todos los sistemas basados en matemáticas,
desde la comprobación más compleja
hasta aritmética básica,
se construyen a partir de axiomas.
Y si una declaración
sobre ciertos números es verdadera,
los matemáticos pueden confirmarla
con una prueba axiomática.
Desde la antigua Grecia,
los matemáticos usaron este sistema
para probar o refutar
afirmaciones matemáticas con certeza.
Pero cuando Gödel entró al campo,
algunas nuevas paradojas lógicas
estaban amenazando esa certeza.
Los grandes matemáticos
estaban ansiosos por probar
que las matemáticas
no tenían contradicciones.
Gödel no estaba tan seguro.
Estaba menos seguro de que las matemáticas
fueran la herramienta adecuada
para investigar este problema.
Aunque es relativamente fácil crear
una paradoja autorreferencial con palabras
los números no suelen hablar
de ellos mismos.
Una declaración matemática
simplemente puede ser verdadera o falsa.
Pero Gödel tuvo una idea.
Primero tradujo declaraciones matemáticas
y ecuaciones a números en un código,
para que una idea matemática compleja
pudiera expresarse con solo un número.
Esto significó que los enunciados
escritos con esos números,
también expresaban algo sobre
los enunciados codificados.
Así, las codificaciones ayudarían
a las matemáticas a hablar de sí mismas.
A través de este método, pudo escribir:
“Esta declaración no se puede probar”
como una ecuación,
creando así, la primera
declaración matemática autorreferencial.
Sin embargo, a diferencia de
la oración ambigua que lo inspiró,
los enunciados matemáticos deben ser
verdaderos o falsos.
Entonces, ¿qué es?
Si es falso, eso significa que
la declaración tiene una prueba.
Pero si un enunciado matemático tiene
una prueba, entonces debe ser verdadero.
Esta contradicción significa que
la declaración de Gödel no puede ser falsa
y, por tanto, debe ser cierto que
“Esta declaración no puede ser probada”.
Sin embargo, este resultado
es aún más sorprendente,
porque significa que ahora tenemos
una verdadera ecuación matemática
que afirma que no se puede probar.
Esta revelación está en el corazón
del teorema de incompletitud de Gödel,
que introduce una clase totalmente nueva
de enunciados matemáticos.
En el paradigma de Gödel, los enunciados
siguen siendo verdaderos o falsos,
pero los enunciados verdaderos pueden ser
demostrables o indemostrables
dentro de un conjunto dado de axiomas.
Además, Gödel argumentaba que estas
declaraciones verdaderas indemostrables
existen en todos los sistemas axiomáticos.
Esto vuelve imposible el crear
un sistema perfectamente completo
usando matemáticas,
porque siempre habrá enunciados verdaderos
que no podemos probar.
Aunque tengas en cuenta estas
declaraciones indemostrables
al agregarlas como nuevos axiomas
a un sistema matemático ampliado,
ese mismo proceso introduce nuevas
afirmaciones verdaderas indemostrables.
Sin importar cuántos axiomas agregues,
siempre habrá declaraciones verdaderas
que no se pueden probar en el sistema.
¡Siempre será Gödel hasta el final!
Este descubrimiento sacudió los cimientos
de las matemáticas,
destruyendo a los que soñaban que
todas las afirmaciones matemáticas
algún día serían probadas o refutadas.
Aunque muchos aceptaron la nueva realidad,
otros matemáticos la refutaron con fervor.
Y otros intentaron ignorar
el recién descubierto hoyo
en el corazón de su campo de estudio.
Pero cuando se probaron problemas clásicos
como indemostrablemente ciertos,
algunos comenzaron a preocuparse ya que
sus trabajos nunca se podrían completar.
Aún así, el teorema de Gödel
abrió tantas puertas como las que cerró.
El saber de la indecidibilidad
en declaraciones verdaderas
inspiró algunas innovaciones clave
en las primeras computadoras.
Y hasta el día de hoy,
algunos matemáticos dedican sus carreras
a identificar enunciados de carácter
indemostrable y demostrable.
Entonces, aunque los matemáticos
perdieron algo de certeza,
gracias a Gödel,
pueden aceptar la incertidumbre
que se encuentra
en cualquier búsqueda de la verdad.